monique is with us in bangor maine hi
monique how are you
very well thank you to kelly for taking
my call today
sure if you got by her your life's good
what's up good move monique
so i am looking for some guidance from
dave and dr delaney about my will
i have two daughters one of whom
is doing very well financially she and
her husband are in the one percent
and the other daughter earns about 50
000 and
for several years i felt uncomfortable
about
how to like divide up the assets i'm an
everyday millionaire but more recently
i i've gotten to the point where i don't
want to give
either of them any money i i feel like
i've worked
so hard my whole life i paid for college
for them
i've paid over a half million dollars
for college for them
and they've turned into socialists and
they just but they have
and and well you sit on
[Laughter]
i'm depressed i'm very depressed about
where i
see my children heading and i
think i don't want my money to go to
them
and i feel terrible about that you
shouldn't they're not entitled they
didn't hit the dna lottery they're not
entitled
my children have been instructed since
they were small
that in order to get the opportunity to
manage the money that god
gave me to manage meaning that i panned
off the responsibility to manage some of
the rams fortune to them
uh they will have to be people of
character socialists are not people of
character
okay there are parasites and so um
if my children are gonna be parasites
i'm not gonna finance their lives so
that they have
a reality show is there a way
to put money in let's say a trust
where they couldn't get access to it to
they were let's say 70 years old well
i mean then they'd just be a 70 year old
socialist right
well but i i'm hoping by then they will
have
kind of woken up you can i put mine is
my
all of our estate is trust based and our
trust is
um we've done it from a faith
perspective not an economics perspective
but uh if they're not walking with god
they don't get to manage god's money
it's what the trust says really yep
and no uncertain terms and so uh
you know in your case you could change
that lingo and just go you know when you
become a capitalist you get the
opportunity to manage this money
monique here's what i would do i would
take some time to distill down beyond
the monikers and the reporters
shrugged what
that's fantastic um man i am not usually
at a loss for words and you got me on
that one
um monique here's what i want you to do
i want you to distill down
beneath the quote unquote word socialist
what are the things that they are saying
that concerns you
that you think that you are leaning into
and i want you to have a
direct straight conversation about what
these
things are and then i want you to
identify them and like dave said it's
your mind you can do what you want to
with it
i i've seen more and more of the last
four or five years a lot of semantic
shale games and what you said i talked
to somebody it's like oh we're way on
the same page
i just thought this about this about
that right i i think you can say
that i you are not required morally
ethically legally spiritually to leave
your money to people that you do not
agree with how they live their lives
period full stop in there right so
now once you've said that then you can
start to have some discussions with them
that are very gentle
and very life-giving and very correct
and very direct very kind and very clear
and it's like okay you know i've paid
for all this stuff for you
and truthfully i don't agree with the
way you're living your life and i'm not
willing to finance that going forward
right
and so it's up to you if you want to do
that i'm not being controlling
i just want to let you know that i'm
going to go ahead and do a reading of
the will and you're not going to be
in it as long as you're living this way
whatever this way is if your kid's a
heroin addict
you sit down with them and go i'm not
funding your heroine but what you think
that is unique is you articulated what
that meant not
you're not vague yeah no no i'm very
clear very cool it's unbelievably
detailed and it cost
twenty five thousand dollars that's
right very clear it's ridiculous yeah
the legal field fees on this were
amazing but
i just you know and and then we get to
have this meeting once a year where we
revisit and go oh by the way remember
what we said if you're going to manage
money for god this is what managing
money for god looks like first you got
to be walking with him
and you know and we do this kind of
stuff and you don't get you know and so
it's not
we're not mad about it we feel a
responsibility
heroin addicts are socialists you know i
mean it's like
wow this is the ramsey show